pathogens miles an upward twitch of his
thin lips that quakes her worse than she
expects good morning honey drop she
whispered into his ear running her
fingers his fur hi welcome back to
millennial Falcon today we are going to
read some fanfiction and I decided to
bring along my best and only friends in
the whole world
Bailey Mayer yeah what what are your
credentials for being appearance on the
show I've known you for a thousand years
and no other credentials you don't know
anything about Star Wars no what is Star
Wars okay
good start let's jump right in I
compiled some good fanfics our theme
today is rare pear so we are going to
read these fanfiction about rare ships
in the Star Wars universe and after we
read this excerpt from each of them we
are going to decide whether it has sold
us on this pairing let's jump into the
first one
Palpatine will be able to help even if
he can only provide his level-headed
advice she remembers the last time they
spoke in the Senate chambers just two
days ago less than a week since had my
blushes alone and embarrassed in the
back of her speeder since the mistake
which is what she calls it even though
her body aches with the memory of the
locker room with Mike and his wiry form
against her soft curves the locker room
so they have lockers in the Senate bill
this is negotiation there so she's gonna
put on irrigation is his office of the
Senate is a wash with red red is both of
the passionate declaration of love of
war of life and death row red also means
warmth the warmth of a mother's womb and
the warmth of coursing blood so
basically she's saying his office is red
and that makes her think of wounds and
sexuality hard not to think of sex stuff
when Palpatine's in the room though you
know oh yeah Rita's dialogue okay got
you dude your Palpatine boy all right
this is my best Palpatine wife yes hello
padmé padmé start and her heart friends
to leap out of her chest at the low
greeting Palpatine is sitting on the
long sofa at the far end encased in the
shadows that play along the edges of the
room and the senator feels a shiver
trace down her spine like slender
fingers chancellor she stammers I didn't
see you there doesn't she have a British
accent
no oh she doesn't never seen Star Wars
god I was some of them do something dire
Natalie Gorman does it she rises and
glides toward her hands now folded in
his sleeves and looking every inch the
graceful and reserved politician the
galaxy has grown to trust my apologies
milady much is on my mind tonight and I
was distracted you look well
she wants him to say lovely she wants
him to reach out and brush his lips
across the back of her fingers like the
nobility of naboombu she clears her
throat
no harm done Chancellor thank you so
much for meeting with me tonight I know
your schedule must be terribly crowded
Palpatine smiles and upward twitch of
his thin lips that quakes for worse than
she expects okay
anything for a friend Padme have a seat
I can bring you a drink and if you
should like your current Palpatine
doesn't sound like your Palpatine three
sentences ago Thank You Chancellor she
says quietly I'll take you up on that
offer
and then beckons her forward she goes
that was a perry sold on Palpatine and
padmé padmé
Padma teen I mean they spent almost no
time together other than in the locker
and wash that alluded to which is not
why I needed to know more about the
locker room I was intrigued but yeah
thus far not sold and I am not sold
either I feel like she's got Anakin as
her hunky evil guy yeah I don't think
she would like go to Palpatine for
comfort no I mean if anything she's
going to go to Jar Jar Binks yeah you're
right exactly Harry I would buy that
work I mean you've got that tongue our
next pick is called the other moon by
Ewok poets oh good I found a walk poet
this author has a lot of different fan
fictions I looked and they've written
over a hundred and twelve thousand
cumulative words on the Ewok pairing of
litera and Peabo that's what George are
and more words on other iguana specific
you've been in litera and tebow are
specifically from the Ewoks cartoon okay
let's jump in
so Chapter six we really are jumping
maybe just Jones in the middle because
there's a lot is anything there was like
19 chapters because all right good
morning honey drop there was no response
this is the Pacific Lazaro leaned over
Tebow and tickled him on the chin he
turned around covering himself over the
top of his head she shrugged and dragged
herself underneath the blanket I said
good morning honey drop she whispered
into his ear
running her fingers I was first oh I
don't like that no she proceeded to kiss
him on the lips
let on a barely audible business and her
surprise he pushed her away Wow
cut that out she almost fell off the hay
bedding but somehow managed to keep her
balance Tebow what is wrong with you
he pulled the blanket and got up what do
you think you were doing I was barely
awake oh is this a lesson on consent
right thank you why oh my god geez you
forgot we were in a relationship come
yesterday our relationship involves
caring about each other you did not do
that last night she put her hands on her
hips and stomps her foot Tebow was now
trying to tie the blanket around his
waist like a row no not how you put a
robe on no I was hoping that you would
come and check on me after I left
mid-conversation with Col waar I was not
feeling well I needed some pain remedy
applied to the back of my head and my
neck and I couldn't do it myself this
whole big system spitefully arguing he's
like you didn't come and put IcyHot on
my neck I'm mad animals II walk married
couple just bickering forever well I
guess that's how you reach 100 and what
29 7 hours I'm kind of extremely
disgusted by the idea of Ewoks having
sex with each other yeah I mean I have a
plush of at least one of these II walk
yeah on my bed or like teddy bears do
not have genitalia well they must but I
don't know I don't want to hear about it
actually I just don't want to hear about
it I'm kind of over this like yeah part
where he flung a towel around his waist
presumably to hide his genitals like a
human I'm kind of over it okay yeah
because I just glanced down and she says
fine do you like how it feels when you
touch me so while I'm not going to bring
them at all okay goodbye you are poet
yeah I you in fair shape we also have
honks Ben Harley Quinn I much prefer
this
[Music]
rumors of possible resistance gatherings
have reached the ears of general Hux and
he has sent to the city in question to
investigate it's a real piteous Gotham
City what and possible resistance
gatherings are the least of his problems
after he is saved by a mystery woman
so what's that cutie lady is doing and
Gotham City he was mildly affronted by
the presumptuousness and
over-familiarity of such a statement but
he overlooked it in favor of keeping her
friendly we were here to investigate the
reports of resistance movement supreme
leader snoke sent me here personally
supreme who what is stupid title Harley
scrunch your nose up at the unfamiliar
name so where are you from I like your
planes are they American what if you
can't hit what it has no civil and sound
she had not even heard of the Supreme
Leader I am not from this area my planes
are typical of those from my home - yeah
Harley wings conspiratorial II I just
want to pause and say I feel like my
Harley Quinn got in college dead-on are
you gonna try and kill best friends cuz
I gotta tell ya it's harder than it
looks
oh no he had no idea what a fat brains
was but he had no intentions of finding
out I'm a sleaze stay dressed happen
again but I will leave you with a gift
take this blaster he handed it to her
and she held out her hands and made a
grabby motion as a sign of goodwill this
city has some interesting points which I
have a further interest in Harley
grinned thanks for the gun but I don't
have anything to give you back she
pouted as she patted down her costume it
is not necessary I am hot he responded
but was cut off when he felt her smack
her lips onto his in a full kit that is
a kiss someone hits there facing up
yours up lowly cat are too shocked to
even move he stood still as she
continued to press her lips to his
eventually Harley pulled away and Hux
was pleased to note that her facepaint
had not transferred to himself I wish it
had and that's us even she nodded
pleased with her solution well it's been
fine mister when you come back to Gotham
just ask about for Harley Quinn Oh
you're somewhere see you those misters
individual items
Oh some imagination this is merely a
real zoo yep well we've read a lot of
good fix and that's it just good fix
good all-around and now it's time to end
the episode okay
should I go are no you just stay home
first comment for my my bad 0 jenny is
the first annoying person i like all in
all I think that's a positive comment so
thank you it's conditional and it will
mean but thank you let's see what the
next column is it might be a little
nicer this is from grass Poehler ing her
annoyingness she's just the right amount
of sneakiness that you need no alcohol
required unless she has been drinking on
the show which is entirely possible let
me rethink this just kidding love the
show okay thanks grass very positive
that's the show goodbye bye everybody
farewell yay bye you can you can walk
off screen now